hello gamespot viewers it's kevin van
oort here and trying world is in the
house today and Andrew with trion worlds
is going to tell us about deville Ian
how are you today I'm good how are you
I'm excellent and I don't know anything
about this game well fantastic so I'm
joined here by Victoria is actually
going to be steering and we're going to
walk through two billion an action RPG
MMORPG so first I will jump into
character creation here we're taking a
look at the evoke er class she's a that
spell slinging class that can cause a
lot of traps and create whirlwinds and
suck enemies into him and then AOE them
down with her big fire blasts
Shadowhunter a whip welding class can
switch between melee and ranged pretty
easily so he's like for a lot of variety
a lot of really cool tricks are
cannoneers a bit of a favorite around
the office she's a trap laying class and
she's very strategic a lot of kiting a
lot of big cannon blasts that kind of
thing and finally our Berserker our
Berserker is that a dual wielding sword
plate wearing character and we're going
to take a look at one of things that
makes dildo villians super unique devil
form so in davillon you have two types
of characters you have your normal
character that you just saw but they can
shift at any moment to De Vil yin and
these characters are supercharged
versions of your character they have
their own experience points their own
gear or their own skills that you
weren't as you play through the game and
will jump on the Shadowhunter so you can
get a first look at this great and I'm
sure you'll answer all these questions
but the first question in my mind is
what are the you know what are the
limitations on entering that form of
course because I'm sure I'm not going to
run around the game all the time like
that so you have a couple of limitations
as you kill themes will collect devil
soul which is both your experience but
also how you transform into two billion
mode so that meter in the bottom of the
screen right there in between your
health and energy mechanic is is how
much time you have to be in davillon
once victoria gets enough double soul by
killing enemy
she'll be able to transform into the
billion interesting those when you're in
PvP which is a huge feature in this game
you're always in two billion mode so
you'll be running around using all the
skills that you've collected all the
gear they equipped but pin PvP we're
heading down onto and if you have any
questions feel free sure sure absolutely
so we're gonna take a look at what
another mechanic go there we go there
and so the Shadowhunter gets a lot of
cool skills you see her her HUD
completely changed out at the bottom or
toolbar so she gains all of the skills
that she's gained from civilian and she
could level that up for PvP from
dungeons from the endless tower there's
a lot of different ways that she can
gain more two billion skills and we'll
walk down to one of the really cool
features and what makes this an MMO over
in a RPG I victorious unfortunately on
our internal server but this is a
persistent world first and foremost so
you'll be running around with tons of
different players you can join with them
you can form groups do dungeons
everything that you love about MMORPGs
just with action RPG combat now when I
first when i was first pitched on the
game that was described to me as you
know what if Diablo 3 were actually a
true mm oh you think that's a pretty
good description of what what you're
going for here in a sense really this is
an MMO first and foremost so when you
think of like mmos like a dungeon run
for instance you go out you form a group
and you do this this instance piece of
content John in davillon for hundreds of
3 and you go into that dungeon and the
boss fights have
coordinated attacks that you have to
learn rity chicly think about is you
have these dungeon runs right that
there's also rates at the end game so
those are up to nine players so similar
to an in-game a dungeon run but with
nine players and then one of the things
that really sets us apart is pvp so pvp
is a 20 verses 20 battle and in that
it's a domination style map so you try
to capture control points and and when
you capture control points it spawns npc
helpers to help slow down your opponents
or you know they join your side help you
out we're looking at one of the world
bosses to another kind of unique thing
about being in an open world so when one
of these guys spawns the whole zone is
is told that a world boss has spawned
and it becomes almost a race to kill him
and unfortunate Victoria is not going to
be able to kill this you no matter how
many potions she is how far is not even
yeah really moving so oh okay yeah you
can see he has for health bars total as
you go through and kill me but I get the
idea of what the world boss is like but
it does sound like you're going through
you know except for PvP which is at a 20
verses 20 correct it sounds like in
terms of adventuring with others you're
going for more of you know I don't know
if smaller is the right word but
something a little bit more friendly
with three people in normal groups and
then only nine people and raids so with
the with grouping that's for a dungeon
content right now we're in the overworld
the the normal maps this could be any
number of players so if you can imagine
all this will be populated players
they'll be doing things like rolled
bosses we have rift events for familiar
with that from rift you know big holes
in the earth open up and demons start
pouring out and becomes contested
players need to try to kill or either a
world boss or as many enemies as
possible erase it along the leaderboard
as well as open world PvP is also a
feature in the game sure now i see here
you've gone for a bit of a different
camera
just to show things off a little bit
more closely but typically is the other
even when you do this or the controls
going to be Diablo esque as opposed to
you know wandering around from a
behind-the-back third-person perspective
is there that option for people yes oh
yeah she is in third person mode um yeah
it really depends on how you want play I
tend to play with the be a RPG
traditional isometric camera third if
you want to play in that or if you want
to zoom in further you can you'll notice
though one of the cool things of
Victoria's to use an accommodation of
mouse look and watched the billion is is
all about having a lot of control over
your character and how they're using
their attacks so a lot of our attacks
are aimed with her mouth while she uses
wasps to move around right on and while
that sounds you know not that exciting
it's actually once you get your hands on
it one of the best feelings in the world
to control on a RPG with laws so do you
are there in that sense you know you're
talking about controlling the the skills
with the mouse oh there you know or
would you say that a lot of it's sort of
AoE based or what kind of what kind of
skills in general do you think drive the
game or at least is this class in
particular so each character class has
three skill trees that can go down each
skill tree has several skills within it
depending every level you get a skill
point that you can invest into your
skills if you find yourself leaning more
towards let's say trap Lane as the
cannoneer and you want invest heavily in
a skill that does that you can invest
more points into there and modify it so
that trap suddenly can you're laying
down more bums when you when you set
bombs or they have a larger blast radius
or maybe they slow the enemy down it
really depends on how your play style
you finding a skill that works for you
as you dump more points into that skill
you gain mastery over that's going
becomes a stronger version of itself
there's a lot of ways to customize your
character one of the cool things about
the billion versus other MMOs is that
there's no Holy Trinity system there's
no healer class for example you find the
skills that you love to play with and we
need to form up with a group or the
challenge is figuring out okay what
skills do we have is a group that we can
use to overcome this dungeon this
challenge sore now Gilmore's two played
around with that idea of not having a
Holy Trinity but there was there was a
downside of that which is
that a lot of a lot of group fights just
ended up being a lot of people mashing
away at one particular at one particular
enemy it just didn't get around that in
some way are there ways that it keeps
you you know invested so they you know
there's there's tactics to the battle
outside of just you know you know smash
smash hash yeah so Victoria is using a
lot of AOE attacks because that's the
way our characters set up and that works
really great specially when you're out
questing and this is a very Questor of
in-game there's a storyline the progress
of Prester as well but you can spec it's
your characters very much on how you
want them to work so if you find like in
a dungeon you have a boss that just
needs a little bit extra defense you
don't necessarily have a tank class but
you can have a class that is Spectre its
tank otherwise you know you might have
to do a little bit more kiting you might
have to find what this the one skill
that you have that will allow you to
overcome that challenge in that dungeon
so tell tell us about this world what
does it stand for what's going on give
me some context for all of this you know
hacking and slashing okay so you're a de
billion there a race of half half humans
half devils and this is a very long time
since the last devil wore the devil wars
were where the de villians came out and
they defeated the the ultimate enemy
chaos so we are planning to release a
couple of lore documents over the next
couple of weeks that are going to detail
out a lot more of the lore in the
background story and what's going on in
the world since the end of the devil war
but needless to say your character he
woke up from a hundred years into the
future and the world has changed but the
emergence of the devils are starting to
come back and in terms of the tome what
do you think what do you think that it's
interesting to me because because when i
saw the splash screen and i see some
elements of visit you know I you know
we're talking about a Korean developer
here correct you know there are some
elements of that but it's interesting
because I see a lot a lot of elements
that don't necessarily fit into into
that tone per usual
in fact it looks of a lot more maybe
even you know Diablo inspired the night
that I would have expected that's really
adorable yeah quite away so so and to me
that that says you know that says hey
this is a Korean MMO but other aspects
say hey this might not be quite what I
was expecting in terms of heart in terms
of morale design and so on um what do
you what do you think they're going for
here what is the the ultimate you know
tone that that you expected really into
hit well there definitely is a dark
aesthetic to the game world um that's
maybe not being conveyed in this
particular don't do well with the
flowers and the butt so corgi dog is
what a example of one of the pets in the
game and there's many different pets
there's some more serious there's some
more playful ones these I love that
little guy he's adorable but the overall
tone it is a dark story line there's
there's some mature constants as well
it's it's oh yeah it's more leaning
towards the mature dark side of things
that being said there's a lot of room
for humor and it's the quest dialogue
stuff like that will definitely convey
that as well sure now sadly we're not
going to get to see any grouping today
Felicia which makes me kind of sad
because I because I'd love to see how
that goes is are there any tools beyond
the fact that you're just adventuring
together things like grip skills and
things like that where you can pull up
really incredible feats that you're not
gonna see unless you're with other
people yeah um so we know like I
mentioned earlier part of the fun of
dungeons is trying to figure out what
the best use of all to the skills that
you have available to you so there's a
duty finder I'm sorry dungeon finder
that pairs you with a two other players
so three people total and like I
mentioned there's no Holy Trinity so you
jump into this adventure with two other
players and you immediately kind of have
to figure out okay what did everybody
spec for what are we what are we in for
and there's a lot of kind of creative
combos that you'll have to start
creating from the skills that you have
in order to overcome these challenges
right civilian has a ton
of ways to customize your character and
make him your own in addition to you
know you're leveling path and getting
the skills and stuff like that we have a
the Deville Yin character grows
independently so you'll be leveling that
and equipping him with gear you have a
talisman system so talisman system is a
way to also grow your character you gain
those through the crafting system and
they are equippable bonuses for your
character that grow as you level up and
they grow by sacrificing talismans you
don't want so for example if you want to
focus on magic attacks you can equip a
talisman that specializes in that and
then sacrifice the talismans you don't
want into that to throw it past that if
you're an MMO veteran you're probably
familiar with the term alternate
advancement we have a whole alternate
advancement system in the game that
allows you to kind of specialized in
customize your character once you get to
more towards the endgame on top of that
there's a gem system that also levels up
that enhances the properties of your
equipment and also your equipment levels
up past a certain rank now you talked
you mentioned crafting for a moment in
terms of the the crafting system in the
game is it fairly typical of a time and
I'm up a little bit of eminem's
apparently is a fairly typical of an MMO
or are we talking about something that
that's maybe a little bit unique the
reason i ask is because a lot of you
know and a lot of MMOs ultimately I end
up not caring about crafting I end up
wanting to just buy the things other
people are making because they're more
patient than I am to collect this stuff
in the first place so is that is that
going to be a viable option for me or is
crafting going to be something a little
bit more core to the average experience
do you think crafting and a billion is
all about using stuff that you didn't
actually need so when you get that item
from a dungeon and you don't need it for
your character I that's when it comes
into the crafting you break that down
into the materials that you use to craft
themes that you do need and that's it
feeds into more of the core gameplay
than I would say you know what running
around looking for a node that has the
iron or whatever right so on the end is
what your is sort of the the kind of
hook that you're trying to get into the
player obviously it's an MMO and so
there are other things to do besides
something that
I'm just going to jump into Diablo and
play for a little while or whatever but
it in the end do you think the hook is
is similar to that in the sense that you
want people to be driven to keep finding
better loot and keep clicking on you
know the enemies because it looks so
cool to watch and you you become more
and more powerful I mean obviously this
is a combat driven game right and so is
that ultimately the hook that you want
to go for in terms of how the player
attaches to the game ultimately the hook
here as in many mmos is the social
element so there's a lot of world bosses
that you can kill and that loot
explosion happens and that's very
satisfying everybody loves that but you
know in MMOs I love to play dungeon
content I love to group up and explore I
love to you know do raids get gear from
that manner big fein in d'ville ian is
guilt so guilds is an extremely robust
system in our game not only you know can
you can you hang out their guild members
things like that but you can form guild
alliances between several guilds who can
join you for anything from open world
PvP to world bosses to ripped events
those kind of things another great
things say for example you made a guild
that maybe you're not friends with you
don't like them maybe harassing you may
be there you know talking crap and chat
or something you can form a guild war
against them and now your guild members
and their guild members are going to be
each other in PvP me each other and
competitive PvE environments it's a lot
of really cool things like that another
feature that I personally really love is
you can give gifts to guild members up
to a certain number per day you get a
free gift to give you get 10 free I
believe still settling on the number
though but you get 10 free gifts to give
a day as you give gifts to guild members
they become stronger your affinity
relationship grows with that person and
the gifts become stronger and stronger
it pays to be the most popular person
basically right Andrew Victoria I'm
really glad you stopped by to show us
deville ian and i'm gonna i keep getting
stuck on the name i keep wanting say
deville yin and it's dave ilion as you
know devil at the beginning so for
anybody that keeps making the same
mistake that I do but this is looking
really good
what are the the release plans do you
have any beta plans do you have you know
you have a release date in mine yeah so
the goal is to have it out 4 2015 4 in a
year so we definitely want players be
playing this game soon we love it at the
office and we have plans to announce our
beta plans very soon so you can stay
tuned on how you can join the beta
participate and get your hands on this
game excellent well there's never too
much loot to find out there so looks
like there will be another way to find
it and guys I'm grateful for you coming
by I'm grateful for everybody that tune
in to watch deville yin and keep your
eyes on the site i suspect that we'll
have even more cool things for you to
watch very soon
you